jesse smollett going absolutely
ballistic in the courtroom after being
sentenced to 150 days in jail for
staging a hate crime
i did not do this and i am not suicidal
and if anything happens to me when i go
in there
i did not do it to myself and you must
all know that i am not suicidal
i am not suicidal and i am innocent i
could have said that i was guilty a long
time ago
so millet will also have to pay a 120
000 to the city of chicago and do 30
months of probation
uh your honor yes um as you watch that
uh you feel for him in ways because
there's something there's something else
going on with him um was this the right
decision uh on the part of the the
sentencing and uh what do you think
happens next
honestly i think the judge could have
given him more time because i have the
statute from illinois he gets one day of
sentence credit for each day of his or
her sentence of imprisonment so 150 days
is really 75 days and what is that a
couple of months in the county jail and
he's asking for protective custody as if
you know i'm so special they're going to
kill me and i'm not suicidal i mean if
somebody acted out like that in my
courtroom i would make sure they got was
sat back down kept quiet until they were
quiet they'd have to stay in the
courtroom they would not leave my
courtroom like that but that is
indicative of everything he did
throughout this case he is arrogant he
is condescending he is everything that
the judge said he was he was convicted
on five of the six counts and in the end
he he imagined and created this racist
homophobic schism in this country that
he's a victim of white mega people in
chicago how many what was the penalty it
could have been what was the range i
thought you were he could have gotten my
understanding was three years on each
count three years on each three years
but you know those would have been was
it five years on each was it five counts
five counts three years on each count
but they probably would have been
concurrent because it's all part of the
same case he's arrogant enough to fight
with the judge and say why didn't you
sentence those two brothers that i hired
that i gave them a part in the plot why
didn't you try them and and and and
charge them with a crime they didn't lie
to the police jesse you lied to the
police you created it you wrote it you
forced law enforcement to spend 120 000
in overtime this is a guy who was upset
because he couldn't get more of an
audience in the courtroom even during
coven and he wanted you know he wanted
his brother uh his brother has given the
judge a lecture on racism in america at
the sentencing these are arrogant people
he's a convicted felon five-time
convicted felon he's going to prison
he's coming out of convicted con that's
the end of it just want to make you
finish yeah
i'm not i'm going to let will get
awarded here yeah well what do you think
was it long enough sentence i mean
because the judge is giving it you saw
the range the judge said definitely not
i think he should have gotten the max if
it's three years if they had run
concurrently then three years is the max
then give him the max because what he
did in terms of this particular crime
perpetuating a hate crime is the max i
can't think of someone who would have
committed this crime in a more heinous
and inflammatory fashion what justice
mollet did is dupination but put a
nation on the razor's edge of a race war
this is race relations set on fire and
it doesn't stop there he was perfectly
fine i guess with the police randomly
rounding up some white dudes and
throwing them in jail for his fake crime
meaning he would have sacrificed the
lives of a couple of individuals
as part of this theater as part of this
entire hoax that is not just as the
judge said profoundly narcissistic
selfish and arrogant that is sociopathic
this is criminal behavior criminal
mindset i hear what you're saying he's
he is a broken man there's something
wrong inside but that shouldn't preclude
him from getting the absolute max i
agree
i just think we now know what it looks
like to audition for msnbc
or the view maybe if they need a dude
they need some testosterone on the view
maybe won't fall out of his seat
um but to will's point he would what if
he incited a riot and he took up the
time of the police officers in chicago
where murder is rampant he has to pay
restitution for of a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars for the overtime spent
by chicago police officers not only
could he have triggered
race riots but what is what did this do
to the people and the victims and the
families who are truly suffering who
deserve those police officers on the
beat investigating those crimes i'll
just add one more thing i just think
people are shocked that he got any jail
time because around here we see people
you know criminals punching people in
the face and sending her to the
emergency room and they don't even get
held on bail
they don't go to jail they don't get
prosecuted but if if this is a racial
issue i'll note that laurie lachlan
spent two months in prison for that uh
college admissions scandal two months so
this is about in line isn't it
prime time
well he's lucky he's not going to
general population because
he can't fight he cried on national
television blacks don't want to have
anything to do with him white so i have
no use for him either i don't know what
the latin guys are going to do with him
either so thank goodness he wouldn't
survive a week gutfeldt said the other
day the reason he hasn't committed war
crimes is because he actually has to
then sleep close to people in prison
that's not the reason you don't commit
crimes you don't commit crimes because
the food in jail is terrible i
researched what they serve
in cook county jail this is your
breakfast
cold cereal
and two slices of bread with margarine
and two packs of sugar lunch
two slices of slimy poor quality bologna
with four slices of bread and then you
get kool-aid dinner is ground slop they
say it's not fit for a dog so he's gonna
wish
he had that subway sandwich that he went
out for past midnight because he's going
to lose a lot of weight next time we see
him hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else